bruselas ha despertado y conmocionada
tras saber la muerte del presidente del
parlamento europeo davidson y debido a
un fallo de su sistema inmunitario es la
primera vez que un presidente de esta
institución muere en el ejercicio de sus
funciones todos los grupos políticos y
líderes europeos ha lamentado el
fallecimiento de este este político
italiano periodista de profesión nacido
en italia y del grupo socialista todos
recuerdan que sobre todo era una buena
persona todas las fuentes con las que
hemos hablado aquí en esta institución
todo el mundo ha lamentado el
fallecimiento de este periodista
italiano sassoli era eurodiputado desde
2009 fue elegido presidente de esta
institución hace dos años en que le ha
tocado vivir una complicada situación
como por ejemplo la salida del reino
unido- de la unión europea así como la
explosión de la pandemia de hecho
sassoli fue el primer líder europeo en
decidir cerrar esta institución debido a
la pandemia también tomó medidas que
fueron consideradas en popular es como
dejar de viajar a estrasburgo a la sede
del parlamento europeo así como también
pasar toda la actividad parlamentaria en
remoto david sassoli acababa su mandato
la semana que viene en que probablemente
será sustituido por la candidata del
grupo del partido popular europeo robert
a nets hola hoy las banderas del
asociaciones europeas pondrán todas a
media asta en señal de duelo